Vermont talk to us about the energy bill
the full title the consumer first energy
act of two thousand eight what are some
of the highlights of this bill what do
you see is its strong points in its weak
points so I could tell you that in
Vermont that I know all over this
country people are up against the wall
now with these outrageously high oil
prices in New England we worry very much
about what happens next winter when home
heating oil prices are also going to be
soaring and if we don't get a handle on
this I can tell you that there will be
people who will be going cold people who
be taking money away from their food
budgets in order to heat their homes so
this is an issue that has got to be
dealt with in the midst of soaring
energy prices there are a couple of
things that are going on that Congress
has got to address and this bill begins
to take a look at I find it rather
absurd and obscene to tell you the truth
ah that oil profits are now at the
highest level they have ever been
ExxonMobil in the last two years has
earned more profits are there any
corporation in the history of the world
we have a gentleman who's head of
Occidental oil who last year pulled in
four hundred million dollars and
meanwhile in my state and in rural
America workers don't have enough money
to fill up their gas tank in order to
get to work so I think we have to take a
hard look at the greed of the oil
companies the degree to which they are
ripping off the American people and tell
them enough is enough my own view and
what this bill deals with is a windfall
profits tax saying to them enough is
enough that's one issue the second issue
which is getting increased attention is
that more and more energy economists
believe that a significant part of the
increase in oil prices is not due simply
to supply and demand or the cost of
production what it is due to is
speculation in oil futures so you have
companies like Goldman Sachs who have
been enormously profitable companies
like Morgan Stanley who are bidding up
prices are which some people think may
amount to twenty-five to fifty percent
of what a barrel of oil is so this bill
begins to address that issue it demands
that the margin rates go up
significantly higher if the man's of the
commodities
futures a commission begin to take a
hard look at XS speculation and
manipulation of the markets what we know
rob is that over the last seven or eight
years we know that Enron of course got a
handle on the electric a market in the
west coast driving up prices they're
beyond belief and we know the fraud that
was involved in that we know that
companies got a control of the propane
gas market we know that natural gas was
also controlled in an artificial way my
own guess is that that's probably going
on with oil and natural and home heating
oil as well so that's another provision
that is in this bill furthermore this
bill addresses the OPEC cartel you know
we have friends here in Washington some
of my conservative friends who who
believe in competition and free
enterprise and yet I think everybody
understands that the function of OPEC is
to exist as an oil cartel to limit
production and to artificially raise
prices so this bill addresses that as
well but the bottom line is we have a
major crisis which is not only impacting
tens of millions of individual Americans
it's impacting our whole economy driving
food prices up other prices as well
talking about the Senate debate on the
energy bill today the numbers are on the
screen callers coming in already first
one from Valdez North Carolina on our
line for Republicans you're on with
senator Bernie Sanders yes I wanted to
ask him about okay first they had a
hearing June to fourth of the Senate
Commerce Committee and chuck Grassley is
that right member okay and they had Mike
greenberger and George Soros and all on
there okay that was really lighting I
loved every minute of it but he says my
Greenberg says that it's a hedge funds
but which I have got awful out of
Washington Post and that their study
investors growing appetite for organs
days market limits hedge funds and big
Wall Street banks are taking things of
loopholes michael greenberg said if that
loophole was closed that right that the
price of all would go down
that tomorrow twenty-five to fifty
percent and they said there's an article
of see here about that okay it says the
commodities markets were never intended
for such large financial players and
they're playing our market and there's a
crook said that you need that limpo
needs to be stopped now you're well I I
agree with the caller absolutely in fact
we talked to dr. Greenberg last week
George Soros as you indicate was also
involved in that hearing and again there
are a lot of energy economist who are
telling us that after oil is produced it
is traded and traded and traded and
traded on Wall Street these guys are
making out like bandits and people are
now paying over four dollars for a
gallon of gas so you're absolutely right
that loophole has got to be dealt with
furthermore a lot of this trading is
taking place below the radar screen
because of the so-called Enron Lupo
which exempts from regulation energy
trading and we've got to rear egg you
late that we need some transparency
there so that wall street does not rip
off the average American to the degree
that's going on right now will the bill
that you're debating today address this
is adults rating yup it does okay next
up Stanton Michigan on our line for
Democrats you're on the washington
journal good morning I is called a
Republican yesterday was who was running
the debate and something about this and
he's one of the ones that talks about
you know so is great but when the sun
goes down you know and implying that all
your electricity will stop you know like
we don't have batteries and you know
stuff like that to scare people and i
call because I just got so frustrated
every time a republican stands up and i
don't care what you're talking about as
far as bills go it can be about a river
and the republicans will get up and the
first thing they say is this is the
biggest tax hike in the history of the
universe okay and the second thing they
is every sense the Democrats came in you
know oh I've gone up you know all this
way I catch all your fault you haven't
earned anything you haven't done
anything I think your comment well let
me let me deal with that um I am an
independent who caucuses with the
Democrats I think politically what we
have right now in the republican party
is a party which over the years has
moved very very far to the right I think
in President Bush now you have a
right-wing extremist president who will
go down in history as certainly one of
the worst presidents that we have ever
had and what he has done in every area
not just the economy not just Iraq not
just health care not just global warming
in every area that you can't think of he
has taken this country in the wrong
direction and when people Republicans
talk about tax ID so let's talk about
what's going on in the economy and
what's going on in the economy today is
very clear is the middle class in this
country is collapsing I ask the people
in Vermont how the economy is doing for
them lately and they wrote me hundreds
and hundreds of people described what's
going on in their own lives in which
they are now used to be part of the
middle class there now struggling
economically just the just to keep their
families together this is going on all
over the United States of America so the
reality of the American economy today
since Bush has been in office five
million Americans have slipped out of
the middle class into poverty median
family income today it has gone down by
twenty five hundred dollars for working
families since Bush has been president
eight million Americans have lost the
health insurance three million have lost
their pensions the gap between the very
very rich and everybody else is getting
wider so what you're saying is a sinking
middle-class the people on top have
never had it so good and we're living in
an economy of greed and it's an issue
that must be dealt with next up Wilson
North Carolina on our line for
independence yes good morning c-span I
wanted to know why we are selling our
all I mean American or this here in
America on the market we were selling it
in futures that mean that they are going
in the ground
they're selling me before come out of
the ground 20 years from now so that
mean that these prices are never come
down and I don't understand you know
this is America's most knowledgeable
charger and not only that but we sell it
on the world market we're not even
selling that to the American people it's
all about money and I want to understand
something why can't we as a people as
American people when important is all
which affect every aspect of the economy
why don't we can we do the same thing
that all kind is doing can't we go to
our own refineries can't we build our
own oil wells and drilled oil out and
sell it to the American people at
because they're to come out of the
ground well that's a pretty that
suggestion would be very very radical
for the United States Congress and not
something that the President of the
United States would give two seconds of
thought about let's be very clear and I
think more and more Americans understand
it while the middle class in this
country is collapsing the wealthiest
people have never had it so good and
right here we're a few blocks away from
the capital on any given day you have
hundreds and hundreds of lobbyists
representing the largest and most
powerful corporations in this country if
you look at the oil companies if you
look at the coal companies they have
spent hundreds and hundreds of millions
of dollars on lobbyists on advertising
on campaign contributions same thing
with the drug company same things with
the insurance companies and clearly what
we need to do in this country's we need
a political revolution which says that
ordinary people have got to stand up and
fight back and that we start listening
to the needs of working people in the
middle class rather than billionaires
and their lobbyists who have so much
influence certainly own the White House
but have a lot of influence on Congress
in the washington post this morning's
headline at four dollars a gallon
rethinking cars rain they also talk
about oil crude oil trading yesterday at
more than a hundred and thirty four
dollars a barrel yesterday what's in
this bill that will bring down the cost
of oil I mean the cost of a gallon of
gas and a cost of barrel of oil well
there were a couple of things uh for a
thought dealing with the issue of
speculation is significant as one of the
quality
indicated there was a hearing just last
week on the Commerce Committee where you
had some economists who know a great
deal about this issue who are estimating
that between 25 and 50 percent of a
barrel of oil right now is not due to
supply and demand that's an issue it's
not due to the cost of production that's
an issue it is due to speculation these
guys aren't producing anything they're
selling it into the future and making
quick profits and if we address that you
can knock down the price of oil
significantly knock down the price of
gas and second of all when we talk about
a windfall profits tax on oil companies
that give their CEOs four hundred
million dollars a year in compensation
essentially what you're saying to these
guys is we're catching on to your rippin
off the American people enough is enough
and I think they will get that message
if the Congress has the courage to do
the right thing and if we can deal with
the president who would be prepared to
veto any serious legislation that hurts
his friends in the oil industry in
addition to the 25-percent windfall
profits tax on major oil companies the
energy bill also has gives the president
authority to declare energy emergencies
price gouging becomes a federal crime if
any emergence if there is any energy
emergency suspense filling the strategic
petroleum oil reserve during 2008 unless
the oil price drops to 75 dollars a
barrel and gives the Attorney General
the ability to prosecute OPEC for oil
price manipulation Rob the provision
dealing with the Strategic Petroleum
Reserve was already passed them will go
into effect on July first next up
Seminole Florida on our line for
Republicans we're talking with senator
Bernie Sanders go ahead oh yes hi but
now of course I'm aware that the market
manipulation is always harder to prove
with oil but in the nature of natural
gas with power forty percent of our
power plants nationwide I didn't know if
they were going to follow up on the
Department of Justice and Texas finished
with I think a hundred indictments
against 12 El Paso gas traders this from
from the 2000 2001 market manipulation
actually I think it was nationwide not
just in the western markets
was the congressman aware that in berk
the Federal Energy Regulatory Commission
had a 2003 document that says el paso
gas manipulated 99 percent of the
northeast and southeast natural gas
sectors of which our power plants are
fueled by the natural gas I would think
that the best market manipulation after
the gas traders for el castlegar Valten
guilty they have pipelines now
nationwide they wear Enron left off El
Paso gas picked up they did own forward
a gas transmission in Florida they have
a monopoly on all of our gas pipelines I
would have thought there would have been
a lawsuit by now since the Department of
Justice tech in Texas had lost thanks
man well the call it raises that same
issue and that is market manipulation
and what I have to say is that obviously
under President Bush there has not been
aggressive action in any of these areas
we certainly know that natural gas for a
number of years was heavily manipulated
prices went up by a particular hedge
fund who eventually collapsed and prices
went down so this whole issue in terms
of natural gas in terms of electricity
in terms of home heating oil in terms of
oil in general has got to be looked at
we know that hedge funds function
primarily in an unregulated market we
know that they're making huge tens of
billions of dollars in profits we
suspect strongly this has a lot to do
with the manipulation of energy Senator
McConnell says that windfall profits tax
would actually drive up gas prices
because the oil companies would just
pass on the increase to consumers
Senator McConnell and many of the
Republicans are apologist for the oil
industry that's there apparently what
their function in life is Senator
McConnell and others actually defend
today the tax breaks and subsidies that
were given to the oil industry some 12
billion dollars now can anybody in their
right mind think it a good public policy
to provide billions of dollars in tax
breaks and subsidies to exxon mobil and
oil companies that are enjoying
record-breaking profits meanwhile we
can't pass the kind of tax breaks that
we need for those people involved in
sustainable energy a Rob in my view one
of the great crises we face not just as
a nation but as a planet is getting a
handle on global warming the good news
is that we can address that problem
through energy efficiency and
sustainable energy the potential for win
for soul of a geothermal for biomass is
enormous and instead of giving tax
breaks and subsidies to wealthy and
powerful oil industries we should be
stimulating the sustainable energy
industry which can create millions of
good-paying jobs clean up our
environment and reverse global warming
next up Wilson Wyoming on our line for
Democrats thank you very much please
give me some time here Rob Bernie we
need a Manhattan type of project in our
energy situation you know that 50 miles
of the coast of Alaska 2,000 feet down
has been found an inexhaustible amount
of methane gas if we begin our engineers
and scientists to be able to tap into
this that could solve a lot of our
products and as per US drilling and then
walk for sure that is going to go on the
world market a BP own you know is
running the gas I'm asking now and
should rent to Japan for refine refine
it we should be using our army and air
force bases are being closed and
building defined meson there for our use
a date that would help us a criterion
run away thank you well I think the idea
of a Manhattan type project where we
where we developed a nuclear weapon in
the middle of World War two is exactly
right in terms of dealing with the
energy crisis i can give you dozens of
examples but right now this is a an ad
about a a plug-in hybrid which gets 150
miles per gallon this is a call that's
on the road the in a prototype form
right now the question is why are we not
producing these cause why our engineers
not working with the private sector in a
crash program Manhattan type program to
build it let me give you another example
terms of energy production right now in
the southwestern part of our country in
Southern California Nevada New Mexico we
have the potential and work is already
beginning to build dozens of solar
thermal plants people are not familiar
with this technology this is not
photovoltaic technology these are large
plants which have the capability of
producing as much electricity as a small
nuclear power plant over 500 megawatts
of electricity there is work now being
undertaken to start building these
plants we can produce fifteen or twenty
percent of the electricity in America
and a cost-effective price by building
these plants in Germany they'll have
hundreds of thousands of rooftops with
photovoltaic panels on their roof tops
we can do that we can build a mass
transportation system revitalize our
rail system yet automobiles that get
really good mileage got electric cars
out there we could do all of these
things create millions of good-paying
jobs reverse global warming and
stimulate our economy that's the
Manhattan type project that we really
need Williamsburg Virginia on our line
for Republicans go ahead good morning
c-span good morning senator good morning
first I'd like to make an observation I
think we're missing the boat here a
little bit in that what are we doing to
conserve energy for instance five
suggestions why not a five-day post a
week I think we could live with that why
not military cutbacks on unnecessary
training flights why not offshore
drilling off the coast of California
they don't mind drilling and our outer
continent on their inner left water land
because why they get money from that but
they don't get money and the outer
coastal shelf you know what we should do
we should give them money to let them
bring that oil in and finally why not go
back to a 55 miles speed limit and my
question to you sir is if you understand
trading a commodity trading you realize
on the near-term month cash has to be
paid for that for that
commodity now yes it can move it into
forward months but the reality is under
the world price on the current month
commodity is exactly cash has to be paid
well cash does have to be paid but the
margin is is very very slim in other
words I don't know exactly what the
margin is but for a dollar you can buy
many many many dollars of oil futures
and that's one of the problems the
gentleman talks about energy efficiency
and while I would look he's absolutely
right well energy efficiency is is the
low-hanging fruit the idea for example
that we are driving automobiles to get
15 or 20 miles per gallon when in Europe
they are driving cars they get twice
that mileage per gallon is totally
absurd we can be moving toward electric
laws in my own state of Vermont we have
made some really significant process to
weatherization efforts and other
programs to drive down the production
the utilization of our electricity there
are light bulbs that are now coming on
to the market LED light bulbs which will
be i think in many many forms within a
couple of years which will consume
one-tenth the electricity that an
incandescent light bulb consumes we
should be pushing that market making
sure that that those light bulbs get
onto into people's homes as soon as
possible but the potential for energy
efficiency is absolutely spectacular we
have a long long way to go we've just
kept the just touched dented the surface
here next up is Baltimore Maryland on
our line for independence go ahead good
morning congressman mana raw my
statement is that you listen to these
Republicans sometimes who call this air
wave and they always talk about we need
to drill in on while we need to drill
home we need to go home congressman I
have a speaking point for you those
individuals didn't want to drill when
gas or oil was at fifty dollars per
barrel because they thought it wasn't
profitable so now that it becomes
profitable to for them to drill at a
hundred and twenty dollars a barrel what
makes these Republicans think that all
company who takes a 20-year investment
will actually reduce the price of their
investment with the knee 20 years to
recoup their money that they would
actually lower the price first of all
because it wouldn't be feasible it would
make sense and another thing that they
would not do when Max being willing made
the suggestion that we nationalize all
oh man they went to fit but it's no
other way to look at it we can't
nationalize it all it's not profitable
for them to drill at fifty dollars a
barrel of Galla of fifty dollars a
barrel why would it why would they
invest that money and then lower the
price well that's an interesting point
uh what I would say to you is that among
other things the Bush administration's
energy department i believe did a study
trying to calculate what drilling in
Anwar would mean for a gallon of gas and
i think the conclusion was that it would
lower a gallon of gas in 20 years by
about one sent a gallon i don't think it
is worth destroying or significantly
harming a pristine environmental area to
do that i think in terms of drilling
where it's environmentally sound let's
do it where it's not we should the real
goal toward an energy transformation
however has got to be towards
sustainable energy of which there is
unbelievable potential and energy
efficiency that is where i think the
gains are going to be our last call for
senator Sanders comes from Groveton New
Hampshire on our line for Democrats go
ahead I can wearing senator I'm what
being one of your neighbors and
everything I would be living at this in
a depressed area right now groves in New
Hampshire all of our bills are closed or
everything um Mike I'm in a designer I
do a mechanical design inc Brett just
not everybody I'd be MBTA and such and
of course that's why trail okay that's
one of the big things that is coming
back you know Mike my question other
domain okay Yellowstone Park has up as a
power source as big as host countries if
we put power plant around that cloud era
in yellowstone park for free we could
link it energizes whole country some
shortish or XP again I think that there
is huge huge untapped potential in
sustainable energy and that means solar
solar thermal power plants it means
photovoltaics it means wind it means
geothermal it means also energy
efficiency it means title uh taking a
hard look at the potential of energy
from tides it is sitting out there and
somebody earlier mentioned we need a
Manhattan type project and a person is
ax it's absolutely right I think the end
result of it is not only we clean up our
environment not only do we reverse
global one we're going to create
millions of jobs stimulate the economy
at putting people to work in these areas
senator bernie sanders thank you very
much for coming on the program my
pleasure in about 15 minutes we're going
to be talking with Corwin Schmidt about
religion and campaign 2008